Happy Valentine's Day America Love Is in
the Air among other things
and I hope my co-hosts are ready to be
seduced because I'm about to tell you
the way to their hearts Dana she's
sweeter than a sugar cube which is what
she sits on during America's Newsroom
but if you take her out to dinner
tonight
don't forget the utensils oh I got my
hotel room and then I walked from the
elevator all the way around and I put
the dressing on the salad and then I
realized I didn't have a fork I ate my
salad with my fingers everybody what a
great working story yes
and under that suit and Ty Jesse's got
the physique of a personal trainer gone
to pot but if you're headed to a
restaurant make sure to bring the tip
money
after they give you coffee and say like
do you want to tip me 10 15 or 20
percent and just like in front of them I
hate about it I'm not afraid to go zero
zero I only stiff sometimes a barista if
they're just giving me the cup wait do I
brag about that yes you do who told you
to shut up
Judge Jeanine is one tough cookie but
here's a sure-fire way to make her heart
crumble
everybody knows that nothing comes
between me and my chocolate the Judge
Jeanine dark chocolate apples and every
time I think of a Peppermint Patty I
have a sensation of a cool breeze
blowing through my hair and across my
long white dress
loves that dark chocolate and the key to
when geraldo's heart is Geraldo Geraldo
's with Geraldo geraldo's Heraldo news
with Geraldo geraldo's Geraldo news with
Geraldo for geraldo's Heraldo news with
Geraldo geraldo's Geraldo news with
Geraldo
so that's the way into all of our hearts
except for mine because I don't have one
we're doing like a fastest on uh
Valentine's Day so we got like three
topics uh Geraldo what are you gonna get
yourself for Valentine's Day
well Erica and I have been together 23
years uh it's wonderful I I have learned
over my long life that Diamonds Are a
Girl's Best Friend but if you are not in
that Financial place then flowers
uh roses orchids
I like something hand wrought every
morning I draw a little sketch for Erica
and there's very special ones for her
birthday my beloved
that was uh and here bring her coffee
the queen of my life
oh and Rise and Shine sweet and the
bottom one I don't know if you could
read it but it is the Valentine's 23
years
said it wouldn't last 23 minutes and
here we are
laughing loving Happy Valentine's Day
you you have the artistic talent of an
incarcerated teenager
that was some of the worst drawing I've
ever seen and I'm not afraid to say so
judge there are any tips any tips for a
good Valentine's Day
no I'm over Valentine's yeah it sucks
doesn't it it's stupid it's stupid it's
a virtue I want to talk now all right
because I can buy myself flowers draw my
name in the sand you know that Miley
Cyrus little too yeah two-step you know
we listen to Barry White through the
whole beginning of this did you draw my
name into sand without using my hands
yeah I don't want to talk about that
today okay okay uh no I think
Valentine's for kids okay but it's great
for business for Hallmark cards for
roses for candy and for diamonds yeah
all those Dead Flowers Dana think about
that they all had such promising lives
and then we throw them in a box and give
it to somebody to impress him I think
about the small business owner who's
selling them yeah I think about them you
should you should support them that's
why you should get them that's what I
got I got tulips tulips is my favorite
flower and but other than that we don't
mean now you got four
other than that we don't do anything for
Valentine's Day that's good that's good
I got no plans Jesse do you are we doing
something tonight uh yeah you didn't get
my car no it's under your pillow oh
fantastic I had big plans for
Valentine's Day and we had lunch
reservations I had ordered the flowers
I've gotten a gift I'd even written a
card we had planned on going rug
shopping after the lunch date your hair
looks great though thank you and then
Jesse Jr threw up all over the house
in the bed
in his room and down in the family room
it's like the Exorcist So not a romantic
Valentine's Day is he sick yeah I think
he's sick or he drank too much last
night yeah oh yeah yeah all right what
are you doing wait a minute I want to
know what you're doing I'm probably
going to sleep you're going to sleep
with Gus yes that's my Valentine's Day
that's like it's a dog America up next
Biden inflation doing number on your
Valentine's Day budget Americans
spending a 200 bucks each and dropping
over 25 billion 25 billion on the
holiday that's like a small War what's
wrong with us America we need this
zielinski's our Valentine yes he's our
Valentine that has to go to the Ukraine
you idiots but it's making it one of the
highest spending years on record gets
down to Dana this is basically a virtue
signal right it's a virtue it's the
first virtue signal
I think you should like this though yeah
because you like it when people commit
and people are looking for love and it's
kind of stressful and it has there's
little anxiety a little fun you got to
get the right present yes don't you
think I think so you know Geraldo when I
forget what I do is Pep I realize the
Pepto-Bismol Wafers taste just like
Valentine's Day candy just take them out
of the wrappers from work and you just
throw them at a distance The Grinch Who
Stole Valentine's Day yeah how did they
give him back I'm asking you two anchor
this was quite a shot for me I mean the
judges right it's great for American
Commerce but also there is a romantic
side of life everything is not hardcore
pragmatism you know ruthless get ahead
at all costs you know sometimes you just
gotta take a breath smell the flowers
recognize what it is that you love in
the person that you are with you know
the The Vibes that you've had the
experiences that you've had think
positive and think in romantic
romance is a wonderful one
how many wives
I've loved them all
23 years I remind you 23 years is it
better to be single judged than married
can I tell you how happy I am yeah I am
so happy you know it's it's the whole
thing I mean I I can do what I want what
I want if I want to go out to dinner or
go to an event like you know I can go to
an event with a guy if I want to and if
I don't I'm hanging out with red Ted and
Stella life couldn't be better I agree
what about uh you Jesse you're married
you got a couple of babies it's gonna be
over soon
you mean my life yes
well so if you're single you have to
spend I would say 500
range in the city for a date on
Valentine's Day because you have the
prefix menu you have drinks and if you
do flowers and you have to do the
flowers at her work because she wants to
receive the flowers out in her private
life she wants to receive them in front
of everybody else and they better be
good and they better just have like the
puny flowers that come to the office
that's embarrassing very embarrassing at
least a dozen mostly I would go with two
dozen roses and then if you're doing a
gift on top that's another 250. so
basically 750. what if things don't work
out Jesse because I think you'd have the
answer for this things will work out on
a date uh would you demand some of the
gifts back
I've done that a couple times yes but I
don't recommend doing that no you you
that's the lamest thing I've ever if
you're single you can't go crazy on
Valentine's Day if you don't mean it
yeah because you're going to give the
girl the wrong impression right and then
you're looking at a Clinger yeah you
really have to play it safe if you're
not interested that serious I would just
take the night off and not go out at all
yeah there you go yeah exactly you could
be great all year round why save it up
for one day that's what I say or why
waste it on one day exactly that's my
goal
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now